I got sick of the censorship on Twitter
so now you can read all my columns see
my podcast videos all at an culture.
subset are they still yes yeah thanks
Elon yeah oh wow Elon hasn't done
anything to help you no and I mean this
kind of annoys me about I mean he's
wrecked it in like 17 different ways but
one of them is he makes this big show of
there's going to be no censorship and
then he brings back like
Nazis gee thanks good favor for us but
he what's wrong with
look I believe in free speech but he
won't bring back um I'll just start in
with the most outrageous things but
people like um um what is it um Jared
Taylor um who write he he was raised in
Japan so he speaks um he's very
gentlemanly very I mean he's the
opposite of a Nazi in that way but he
only writes about race he's still
banned from Twitter and I am 100% still
Shadow ban I've